[Musique]
nous allons tous mourir alors pourquoi
avons-nous si peur de parler de la mort
et si en parler nous permettait de
l'accepter et de mieux vivre avec
peut-être avez-vous déjà eu un ami qui
vous a raconté la perte d'un être cher
qu'avez vous fait avez vous essayé de
changer de sujet pour parler de quelque
chose de plus gai ou avez vous écouté
avez vous accueilli ce qu'ils avaient à
vous dire on n'ose pas parler de la mort
ça fait peur et ça fait peur parce que
c'est inéluctable
connaissez-vous un organisme qui au lieu
de mourir prolifèrent il en existe un
c'est le cancer nos cellules ont un
programme d'auto destruction mais
lorsque celui-ci ne fonctionnent pas
plutôt que de mourir nos cellules vont
proliférer et vont devenir un cancer qui
va nous tuer ironique non on a si peur
de la mort qu'on arrive à en faire des
choses inhumaines
lorsque j'étais plus jeune j'ai vécu la
fin de vie de ma grand mère elle était
fatiguée elle ne pouvait quasiment plus
bouger et elle a décidé d'arrêter de
manger des membres de ma famille ont
alors décidé de l'intuber contre son gré
pour qu'elle continue de se nourrir
j'ai trouvé cela vraiment choquant si la
peur de la mort nous amène à faire des
choses inhumaines
je pense que nous avons un problème de
société mais évidemment la mort rend
triste la perte l'absence d'un être cher
rend triste c'est évident et nous ne
sommes pas faits nous nous n'avons
jamais vécu ça nous ne sommes pas
préparés à un tel choc
alors que faire de cette tristesse
peut-être vous même avez vous déjà vécu
la mort d'un être cher
à ce moment là avez vous eu besoin d'en
parler de dire les liens qui vous liait
à cette personne vous n'avez vous pas pu
en parler et est encore aujourd'hui une
blessure parler des êtres chers permet
de conserver leur mémoire et donc
l'amour que nous avons pour eux faire
son deuil
ce n'est pas oubliée partout dans le
monde les gens sont tristes à cause de
la mort mais partout dans le monde
aussi il existe un métier pour faire
sortir cette tristesse peut-être
connaissez-vous les pleureuses
ce sont des femmes en général qui vont
exprimer la tristesse à la place des
familles ce métier existe depuis plus de
3000 ans en france il a disparu il ya à
peu près 60 ans et en chine par exemple
il existe encore on appelle ces femmes
des cluses en grain fait qu avant rennes
organise l'ensemble de l'enterrement
pendant ce moment elles vont pleurer se
lamentait hurler se déchirer les
vêtements et parfois même se griffer
elles ont un exercice difficile
elles doivent exprimer la tristesse sans
elle même est triste et pourtant c'est
tout un symbole parce qu'en plus de
d'exprimer cette tristesse elles doivent
aussi faire rire
après la tristesse elles vont faire des
exercices de clown pour que après la
mort et la tristesse reviennent la joie
et la vie au togo
la population des bassar ont un rituel
particulier qui transforme les morts en
ancêtres à partir de ce moment là les
personnes n'importe qui même peut
questionner les ancêtres grâce à un
devin pour poser des questions du
quotidien
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux que j'épouse ace
à tous ou fatima
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux que j'achète une
chèvre ou un paquet de graines les morts
deviennent des ancêtres et par là-même
ne sont plus une source de tristesse
ils sont une aide précieuse au quotidien
remontez maintenant dans vos souvenirs
essayez de vous rappeler qu'en pour la
première fois vous vous êtes dit que
vous pouviez mourir
qu'avez vous ressenti avez vous été
effrayés des études montrent que à
partir de 6 ans les enfants se rendent
compte de leur propre finitude et que
cela les effraie
si bien que certains n'arrivent plus à
dormir et que les parents sont obligés
d'inventer des histoires de leur
raconter qu'ils ne vont pas disparaître
que leurs âmes ira au ciel ou paradis ou
que sais-je peut-être est-ce cela qui
nous fait peur disparaître le vide ne
pas savoir où nous allons et pourtant
d'autres études montrent que lorsque les
enfants apprennent à connaître ce qu'est
la mort biologiquement c'est à dire la
décomposition d'un corps qui va nourrir
d'autres êtres vivants ils ont moins
peur de la mort et c'est à ça que
servent nos cultures dans l'ensemble des
cultures autour du monde
des rites existe des fêtes pour se
rappeler de la mémoire des morts pour ne
pas les oublier pour qu'ils ne
disparaissent pas je vous propose un
petit voyage dans le temps et dans
l'espace
nous sommes il y a trois mille cinq
cents ans en egypte la reine pharaon
hatshepsout la plus grande souveraine de
l'egypte antique vient de mourir
elle est enterrée dans le temple des
verts des verrous le sublime des
sublimes temple qu'elle a fait
construire pendant sa vie pour
commémorer son règne et sa place auprès
du dieu amon
pourtant aujourd'hui si vous allez
visiter le temple des verts 2 0
vous ne verrez aucune mention du nom
capce août
des personnes ont voulu effacer cette
mention ils ont tout fait pour qu'on
oublie la souveraine pour que plus
personne ne se souvienne d'elle la pire
des vengeances qu'on ne se rappelle pas
de vous maintenant essayer d'imaginer
votre propre mort
pas évident mais qu'avez vous envie
qu'il se passe comment voulez vous que
vos proches vivent votre propre mort
dans l'imaginaire collectif en france
souvent on imagine un cortège funèbre
est sinistre silencieux c'est une image
qui vient du monde catholique mais qui
n'est pas si ancienne que ça cela vient
du 15e siècle à l'époque les riches
penser que pour racheter leurs péchés il
fallait commémorer des messes et donc
ils paient des pauvres et des prêtres
pour participer à leur propre cortège
ce qui a donné aujourd'hui c'est le
cortège mais aussi la bille noire que
nous portons pour le deuil mais dans le
monde il existe des milliers de manières
de commémorer la mort de la fêter et de
la rendre beaucoup plus joyeuse imaginez
maintenant que vous habitez à la
nouvelle-orléans autour de votre
cercueil un orchestre qui joue des notes
de musique discrète et les gens qui vous
qui vous accompagnent sont de toutes les
couleurs habiller toutes les couleurs il
ya des parapluies orange bleu vert les
choses extrêmement gay à la sortie du
cimetière lors qu'elles se mettent à
jouer un rythme endiablé tout le monde
se met à danser à faire des des
pirouettes acrobatiques tout le monde
exulte de joie encore un symbole passé
de la tristesse et de la mort à la joie
élèves
mais c'est quand même un petit peu plus
sympa imaginez maintenant que vous
habitez à moscou en russie
pour fêter votre mort tout le monde
vient manger un repas immense sur votre
tombe
sympa peut-être avez-vous même prévu le
coup et vous avez fait construire une
une table juste à côté de la tombe pour
être sûr qu on vous oublie pas manger
accomplir le geste le plus essentiel à
la vie pour fêter la mort c'est quand
même pas mal
vous sentez-vous vivent aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être vivant pour
les bambara au mali les enfants qui
naissent ne sont pas considérés comme
des êtres vivants pour le devenir
ils doivent passer le corps et ils
doivent affronter les différents visages
de la mort à cette condition seulement
ils sont vivants et vous aujourd'hui
comment vous voulez vous célébrez la
mort comment voulez vous vivre la mort
de vos proches
la tristesse est surmontable
nous allons tous mourir alors parlons-en
simplement
[Applaudissements]